salut à tous donc on se retrouve pour
une petite vidéo de pessah léman voilà
comme prévu on se retrouve sur un spot
on a trouvé pas mal de parties d'une
moto donc des vidéos déjà tourné avec le
conteur etc
avec le conteur promet le gros pot
d'échappement pour voir la taille ce qui
semble être un feu une porte
auteur tirer alors j'ai trouvé le cadre
également été 100 m la roue avant mais
comme chez sun j'ai pas pu la sortir
donc reviendrait donc là on est revenu à
deux peut-être qu'on va y arriver cette
fois ci on appris la tenue pour
descendre dans l'eau au cas où mais on
espère ne pas ne pas s'en servir parce
qu'il fait pas très beau
voilà on va commencer à pêcher tout de
suite et on va voir ce qu'on arrive à
sortir on reprend donc il semblerait
qu'ils soient ici on a enfin retrouvé
voilà encore deux rouges maintenant on
fait ça c'est plus simple une prise on
accroche l'accord de rouge dans le
bitume
alors tu es très pop
hop
et voilà
non
à bientôt
tarson et plus loin dans le pare choc de
la voiture sa plaque non merci
la sagesse une moto châssis moto
mon set
tous partis
on fera des recherches pour voir à quoi
ça ressemble comme moto ain
mais un autre boulade autocollants s'en
remettra aussi les balades avec les
vidéos du conteur qu'on a trouvé là le
jour voilà donc pour le compteur donc si
vous avez une idée de quel conteur ça
peut être on n'a aucune idée on a essayé
de chercher un peu mais on n'a rien
trouvé chez ressembler voilà le chrome
est encore bien brillant mais à part ça
y'a pas grand chose à en tirer
on voulait le démonter parce que ça a
l'air encore joli ce qui absout mais
c'est assez compliqué et touques et
rouillée accroché on va voir si on
essaye de l'ouvrir ou pas keller n'a
accroché c'est important
y'a pas moyen de faire un noeud quand un
patient qu'on n'a pas pu dormir mais
contiendra et en tire droit
c'est une grosse plaque en fonte en
direct ça le faire ailleurs il va
apprécier
c'est trop loin
qu'est ce que ça peut être trop loin et
c'est sûrement un coffre en effet ok
donc si je crois bien que c'est un bon
coffre ça va être compliqué tiens en
poussant vers le coin bien il est
tellement dur que quand même pas que je
me le coin sous le pied ou quoi bon vous
dire qu'il est vraiment prêt d'oublier
trimestre en tee shirt de la fuite alors
tout est calé
beaucoup donc voilà on est en immersion
la gopro n est pas dans sa coque j'ai un
petit peu peur pour essayer de vous
filmer ça au plus près du danger voilà
c'est peut-être cette racine qui nous a
pas mal bloqué aussi c'est sûr que
c'était impossible de remonter avec sa
classe que je vais faire c'est que j'ai
essayé de pousser vers la dans un
premier temps cette heure je veux sortir
le nom j'essaie de décrocher les aimants
après huit ans à temps sinon la voiture
si je fais doucement sur voit que ça ne
fait pas ça le fait pas
c'est le coffre qui remonte m'a dit
y aller manqué venu jusqu'à la voiture
et où il a failli casser l'oeuf
j'ai cru qu'il avait tapé dans la
voiture gros mais je crois que c'est en
train de tourner mec j'ai cru qu'il
allait casser la vitre de casser leur
garde à distance la wii lors de la
détection
il semblerait qu'un truc c'est bizarre
ça fait une grande sensation la forêt
pas du pur métal non j'étais un grappin
quand on regarde la gelée on va voir ce
que c'est un jour mon paiement
glissement et c'est que ça bouge c'est
un gros truc du coup ça change de format
1-1 au bout c'est un beauf et la porte à
une portière et rappela par là je la
soulève ne peut pas il le reste étant
couvert par la voix comme ça qu on peut
l'accrocher de la tâche et reviennent
donc vous tenir la cale déjà comme ça à
trois mâles les costauds j'ai acheté
sous richard deschamps
ok
ah oui quand même
ah ouais c'est votre portière serment
encore ses portières arrière coffre
ouais on applique un push patois voyons
bien découpé mais il y en a d'autres
morceaux que l'on doit il avoir des
morceaux un peu partout du coup il ya
une voiture et une moto dans le coin
ouais bon et sans la voiture élections
sans bon ouais c'est notre vie en
voiture un homme a payé en perdre une et
en gagner une autre
aujourd'hui donc maintenant je vais vous
montrer une espèce très rare
on appelle ça du poisson de portières de
portières et la peur aux petits la pêche
non seulement je mange crue du gard
ouais pour la vidéo sauvetage réussi
alors que vous allez sont gentils ils
nous ont fait des petits morceaux
aujourd'hui voilà [ __ ] c'est pas la
même voiture
non non c'est pas vrai c'est pas la même
ou alors il avait fait un mélange de
verre et de gris métallisé mais je pense
pas bon on va continuer c'est le
cimetière des voitures on sait pas tout
jeune on vous remet pas
on a quand même décroché un truc tu
parles aller à la chute chez ouais ça
bien on va doucement quitté croche pas
d'ailleurs même moto vous là où tu as
tes pieds ce même pas le alors [ __ ]
[ __ ] de jeu
chaque fois ça ressemble à un bout de la
même la grèce s'aggrave au delà des
jeunes recule un peu c'est pas se fasse
un petit c'est un petit bois ces mêmes
boucles autres on dirait presque ça
ressemble à l'autre mais peut-être un
autre nom oui sûrement
hop
alors qu'est ce que c'est sa renault
c'est une renault regarde c'est l'autre
bout c'est le bout parallèle à les
automobiles françaises
qu'est ce que c'est beau pécheur pécheur
de trésors ou pêcheurs de renault c'est
plus qu'un trésor
mais là on a affaire à des sacrés
découpeur hockey oh ça glisse 6 mais il
est trop lourd on n'a pas réussi à le
sortir mais ouais là c'est une renommée
on sait pas encore une fois après on
amènera tout offert ailleurs
nous aussi on commence à se filmer on
essaye aussi de faire une chaîne
ouais c'est incroyable attends tu tiens
juste à traverser au mieux non mais ça
va pas tenir et c'est pas sûr non mais
au mieux dans le trou j'vois pas trop
les patrons n'ont pas trop mal dans ce
truc savais pas trop ce truc travers
quoi je veux vous le christ ou grâce à
leurs trousses de gamme le ca non mais
ça la balance en votre nom
ainsi partir à mon petit des baffes
s'était fâché le creux si c'est creux
bouge assez cru mort je t'aime d'une
heure c'est que ces jeunes chiens on est
là quoi c'est un bouquet pénible c'est
ça
voilà presque oui mais non en fait ouais
on fout tu attends je trouvais dans la
rive avec rocher un autre endroit aussi
rimane attrapé ou quoi vas-y show pas
vous [ __ ] continue à chanter de me
couper les mains c'est mort
hélas hélas pour ses rails là haut qui
retombe d'un camion non je crois que
c'est
vert mais dans le temps vers un mieux ce
que c'est parce que c'est encore un
sacré boulot ici on va faire une pause
là il va faire nuit on reviendra plus
tard
[Musique]